ARDAN ARAC: OK.
Well, welcome to our session.
We're very excited to
have you here today.
And I know it's late in the
afternoon, so you're probably
pretty tired.
But we have some truly exciting
stuff to show you.
Today, we're going to show you
how you can transform your
brand queries on
Google search.
JOHN HJELMSTAD: And we're going
to do that through the
power of the Google+ API,
Google+ pages, as well as the
Google+ Sign-In API and
related technologies.
ARDAN ARAC: I'm Ardan from
the search team.
I'm a product manager.
And in the first half of the
talk, I'll be walking you
through the user experience,
and what is possible.
JOHN HJELMSTAD: And I'm John.
I'm an engineer on Google+.
And I'm going to, in the second
half of the talk, tell
you how you can actually
implement this, and in fact,
get your part of the equation
rolling today, in as little as
half an hour, to provide
this integration.
ARDAN ARAC: Today, we'll be
mostly talking about a class
of queries that I call
brand queries.
These are queries like
Audi, NBC, Fandango--
people coming to Google and
searching directly for you.
So the first question
to address is,
why should you care?
People are already
looking for you.
Who cares what the Google
results page looks like?
Well, for many of your users,
current and prospective,
Google is the first interaction
point for your brand.
On the internet, it's not really
your home page where
you make the first impression.
It's the Google search
results page.
And this is what the page looks
like for a lot of you.
And this is a very great page.
It's very useful, gets
the job done.
But today, we'll show you
how you can get to this.
The first thing that strikes me
when I look at this is how
much more beautiful it
is, more visual.
The logo is there.
The movie posters are there.
Before, and after--
but it's not just pretty
for prettiness' sake.
It's also very useful.
At Google, we're all about
relevance and bringing useful
content to the users.
So let's think about
the use case here.
I come to Google searching
for Fandango.
On the right hand side, I see
the most popular movies that
are trending on Fandango across
their website or mobile
app right now.
So the fact that "Oblivion" is
the top movie, it's pretty
likely that I too am interested
in "Oblivion," or
one of those four movies
we're showcasing here.
So my eye goes there.
My mouse goes there, and I
click on it, and here.
I'm on "Oblivion"'s page on
Fandango, ready to complete my
transaction.
It is so much faster.
And if beauty and efficiency and
relevance don't convince
you, perhaps math will.
Here, you doubled your footprint
on Google's search
results page.
You doubled the number of
links pointing to your
website, and you supplemented
the page with even more
relevant links relevant now.
Here's another example.
Let's say I heard about TuneIn
last night from John.
He mentioned he uses it.
He loves it.
I barely remember what it was or
why he liked it, so I come
and Google it.
This is what I would
see today, but this
is also what's possible.
The first thing, the
logo is there.
So maybe it rings a bell.
Maybe I remember seeing
TuneIn elsewhere.
If not that, underneath
it, I see CNN's logo.
I see BBC radio.
I immediately you start to
understand TuneIn is where
people go and listen to
these radio stations.
6,000 people seem to be
listening to CNN.
As in the example of Fandango,
if I click on one of these
links, I'm on the right page,
ready to consume the content.
There's also another point
I want to make here.
Everything you see in this
card comes from TuneIn.
It is specified by TuneIn.
So basically, since the clicks
go to TuneIn, we want to give
as accurate a representation of
those pages that we'll be
taking the user to
as possible here.
So the logos, the text, the
descriptions, all come from
schema.org markups.
And John will be getting
into the weeds later.
Let's take a closer look.
So we talked about the logo that
comes from the Google+
profile page.
But there's also the follow
button that allows the users
to follow your brand directly
from search.
And why does that matter?
First of all, you're building
a relationship.
You're building a community.
So from this point on, any post
that you post on your
Google+ profile will appear
in that user's stream.
But there's also another
point here.
As a search team, we now know
that this user cares about
your brand.
There is an explicit signal
that they gave us
by following you.
So that goes way deeper than
just the brand query.
Having that kind of an explicit
signal, explicit
affirmation from the user that
they like you, that's the type
of thing we love and integrate
into search.
So building a follower base
is a general good to have.
That pays many dividends
down the stream.
We didn't talk about recent
posts, so I want to spend a
little bit of time
on this one.
So this is the voice of your
brand coming from your Google+
page in realtime on
search results.
So when would that be useful?
How about product launches
or product announcements?
We all work towards these big
milestones where we announce
something and we want everyone
to hear about it.
So in this case, BMW, who has
launched a new customization
tool for their interior design,
puts a post about that
launch, about that announcement,
right on Google.
And perhaps the reason someone
is searching for BMW on that
particular day is because they
heard about this through a
different channel.
And there's that nice blue link,
and clicking on it goes
to this nice album posted
on Google+.
However, all links don't
need to go to Google+.
That's not the point.
For some announcements, maybe
the appropriate link is to the
page on your website.
So here, with Verizon's
announcement, the link doesn't
go to Google+.
For BMW, that made sense.
They wanted that visual
experience.
But for Verizon, they want to
maybe sell the product.
So they included a link
to their product page.
Examples are really endless, but
I want to walk you through
a couple others.
So you can also use this
to upload all kinds of
interesting, relevant, timely
information, such as events
that you're hosting.
You can also use it to post
realtime updates from the
events themselves.
Or perhaps promotions, coupons,
daily deals--
but here's another one that
I really like, and this
emphasizes the realtime nature
of this integration.
So every once in a while,
something unexpected happens,
and that you want to deal with--
like, say something
about, with urgency.
In this example, perhaps
something happened in your
local community, and you want to
get your message across as
quickly as possible.
Well, this is a great
distribution system.
You can--
as the CEO of the company, or
the PR person, marketing
person, whoever--
type up a post from your mobile
phone, hit send, and
within less than a minute, that
message is going to be on
Google's search results page
for people looking for you.
And here, maybe you make direct
eye contact with the
user who's searching for
you with your written
message next to it.
And not everything has to
have a time component.
All the examples I walk through
were about events,
promotions, et cetera.
But sometimes, you just want
to show the best of their
pages, best of your content,
with pretty pictures, on
search results page.
And this is the last section
I want to talk about.
I already alluded to it at
the beginning of my talk.
We are just beginning to release
this new module that
shows people who are looking
for you, what is popular,
what's trending on
your site or app.
Well, how do we know
what's popular?
Google+ platform team released
Sign-In with Google
functionality that I hope all
of you are considering or
adopting to your website
and mobile app.
So users come and login with
their Google ID to your
service, be it on mobile
or desktop.
Then with their consent, you
can send us the activities
that those users are
engaged in--
the songs that are being
listened or the movies that
are being purchased.
So then, one of the first
integration points of this
data into Google search is
what I'm showing here.
We aggregate all those
activities, find out what is
trending right now, and then
put links into them with
accurate descriptions coming
from your web pages into these
right hand side cards.
So Google+ Sign-In is--
basically, we will be having a
lot more integrations on top
of Google+ Sign-In, and this is
the first starting point.
So with that, I hand over to
John, who will be talking you
through how to get to
these features.
JOHN HJELMSTAD: That's right.
Thank you, Ardan.
So this is a really exciting
opportunity to actually have
the ability to have your voice,
as well as the voice of
your users, on your Google
search results page for your
brand query.
And that's almost
unprecedented.
In fact, actually, it
is unprecedented.
And you might think
to yourself, how
can I make this happen?
And the great news is that
it's incredibly easy.
I'm going to describe today
two different levels of
integration that you can do.
One is so simple that within
the span of half an hour's
worth of time today while
sitting in Google I/O, you can
get your portion of this ball
rolling to activate the right
hand search box to begin with.
All that involves is having an
activated +Page that also has
current posts that have been
posted quite recently on it.
The second level of integration
that I'm going to
describe is integrating
Google+ Sign-In.
Google+ Sign-In, in turn, as
Ardan mentioned, allows you to
send activities with the user's
consent to Google,
which we in turn can pass back
to you in the form of
promotion in the right hand
search box on the popular
Google+ box.
Let's get into the details.
First level of integration is
what I call basic integration.
All you need to do to activate
the right hand search box is
to have a Google+ that you've
created that claims a website
that corresponds to your
Google+ brand query--
excuse me, your Google
brand query.
And then that page in turn will
have validation code on
at that points back to your
+Page to ensure that the +Page
is yours and you
are the +Page.
The second level of
integration is
to integrate Google+.
You integrate Google+ to tell us
who is doing activities on
your site, what those activities
are, and then with
the help of schema.org, you'll
be able to tell Google's
search engine more about the
page, such that we can render
something relevant and
contextual for the user.
So let's dive right on in.
First thing to do is
to set up a +Page.
Many people here have probably
already done so, but if you
haven't, it's incredibly
simple.
You simply just go to Home,
Pages, Add a Page, and you'll
go through a very easy
to follow flow.
And I'll walk through some of
the most relevant fields
associated with that.
There's quite a few others,
many of them quite
self-explanatory.
So in this case, we're talking
about a product or a brand in
terms of classification.
And you'll give your product
a brand type.
The two fields that are
most relevant are the
most obvious ones.
One is your name--
pretty straightforward.
That name will show up directly,
prominently, and in
large text in the right hand
search box on the top.
The second is your website.
The website is what
you were claiming
corresponds to that +Page--
pretty straightforward.
For best results for that +Page,
execute your brand
query directly yourself, and
simply just copy and paste.
Make sure that there's a
one-to-one correspondence.
It might not necessarily be
absolutely required, but to
make things easy, just
copy the URL directly
into the claim box.
That's fairly simple.
The last stage, which I don't
show on this slide, is simply
just to have your
profile image.
The profile image is what
shows up in the top left
portion of the right
hand search box.
So that's great.
At this point, you
have a +Page.
You've claimed the page
that corresponds
to your brand query.
That's not quite enough, because
of course, anybody
could do that.
The last thing you need to do
is add code your page itself
that validates that that
page is yours.
Now there's a number of
different ways to do this, and
previous talks actually today,
including Paul Linner and
Chris [? Macinez, ?]
having to do with our new
Badges, provide some
techniques to do that.
The first technique that I'm
going to describe is to add a
widget to your page.
And the widget could either be
a Brand Badge, which we see
here on the right, or a Follow
button, which you also see
here on the right.
The Brand Badge is a
beautiful, small
representation of your +Page
that you can embed
anywhere on your site.
But if it happens to be on your
home page, Google search
crawler will see this
and take that as
validation of the page itself.
The same is true for
the Follow button.
The Follow button is a lighter
weight version of this.
You'll notice that Follow
exists in the
Brand Badge as well.
And Follow provides yet another
way that you can embed
anywhere in your site, but in
particular, on your claimed
page, to indicate that the +Page
is yours, and to allow
users the ability
to establish a
relationship with you by following.
And then finally, if none of
these work for your particular
UX reasons or others, you can
simply just add a link tag,
which has no UX associated
with it whatsoever, or a
direct link to your +Page.
Once Google search crawlers
crawl your page, they will see
this and take this as
validation, at which point
you're pretty much done.
How do you know that
this has happened?
You go back to your +Page, and
then take note of the URL here
for TuneIn.
If there's a small check boxes
just to the right of it,
Google's crawlers have
found, crawled, and
validated your page.
At this point, you're completely
done, and you can
activate the right hand
search box simply by
adding Activated Posts--
excuse me, Active Posts, which
is the last stage in the basic
integration--
very simple.
It's the same as posting a share
or a post your personal
stream, only, of course, it
corresponds to your +Page.
Now, there are two requirements
associated with
posts that are required
to trigger the
right hand search box.
The absolute requirement is
that you have some text.
We need to provide additional
information in context.
But of course, it is strongly
recommend as well to either
have a link or an image.
The image will be displayed
directly on the page,
providing that it can
be, of course.
And then if you provide a link,
Google's crawlers will
crawl that link, find an image
from it, and display that as
well in the right hand side.
And here we have a couple
of examples.
TuneIn is promoting a Deadmau5
concert with a link.
That link was crawled on
TuneIn's website, and the
image appeared accordingly.
In the second particular
example, an image was provided
directly, which corresponds
to the text.
And that's pretty much it.
It's incredibly simple.
And like I said, your portion
of this can be done in as
little as 15, 30 minutes today,
simply by starting up
your +Page, claiming it, and
then providing validation.
Google search crawlers
will do the rest.
So before and after is an
incredibly powerful
demonstration of this technique
and this technology.
So from here, I'm going to
talk about the deeper
integration.
And this is something that, as
Ardan mentioned, is already
paying dividends, but is
becoming more and more
powerful as we continue to add
features of the Google+
Sign-In platform.
And this involves integrating
Google+ Sign-In, and then
sending app activities with
users' consent to Google,
indicating activity that is
going on on your site.
Now, thinking about this in a
very straightforward fashion,
if you look at the Popular on
Google+ side, we need to know
how many users are doing
something, and what they're
doing, and then to be able
to represent that.
Corresponds to three concepts.
First of all, who's
on your site?
This is conferred by adding
Google+ Sign-In to your site.
Second, sending app
activities--
what is the user doing,
and on what page--
which is represented as a URL,
which we'll see in details--
does that activity apply?
And then third, Google's
crawlers
will crawl those URLs.
And you can provide a way using
schema.org to tell us
how to best render that content,
so that when the user
sees it in Popular on Google+,
will get an accurate
representation of where
they're about to go.
Let's dive into the details.
First thing to do is to
integrate Google+ Sign-In.
Now, there are a number of
different talks in Google I/O
today that will give you
a lot of the details .
And it's important to recognize
that you can do this
for web, Android, or I/O.
Everything that applies to
this talk has to do it either
web- or app-related
activities.
For the purposes of the
discussion today, I'm going to
go through the web flow just
as an example, just to show
you how simple it will be.
However, there are a number of
different talks, all of which
are tomorrow--
a deep dive into integration on
web, Android, and iOS-- and
I strongly encourage you to
check out any of them if they
are of interest to you.
So the first thing to do in
integrating to a Google+
Sign-In into a webpage
is to add the
Google+ JavaScript snippet.
And this activates all APIs
that Google+ supports.
This includes +1, Brand
Badge, Follow widget.
It also allows you access to the
Google+ Client, with which
you can send activities
to Google.
It's a pretty straightforward
piece of boilerplate that you
more or less just copy
and paste once
onto any given page.
And then from there, what you
would like to do is add a
Google+ Sign-In widget.
The widget is activated, as
all other widgets on the
Google+ platform are, with a
small snippet of HTML5 markup.
This provides an example
of the Sign-In widget.
As you'll notice, it's
simply just a span
which has a class g-signin.
All widgets have class equals
g dash something.
And in this case, it's
a Sign-In widget.
I'll go through a couple of the
other parameters that are
relevant to this integration,
as well as all integrations
that have to do with Sign-In,
just to give you a little more
flavor for the important factors
that are involved in
integration.
And the first one is the
callback parameter.
In the case of web, when a user
goes through a Sign-In
flow, a JavaScript function
is executed with the
result of that flow.
And what you need to know
is simply one thing.
Was it successful?
And if it was successful, at
that point, you can start
sending app activities
back to Google.
Let's take a look at
what the JavaScript
function will look like.
This is very simple.
And of course, we can
go into more detail.
I recommend that you go to the
web talk tomorrow, or watch it
on stream if you'd like.
Here, we're defining
a function called
handleAuthResult.
It takes in a result object.
For the purposes of the
function, it simply just looks
like a standard object.
And it either has as
one of two fields.
Access token--
if that token exists, the flow
was executed successfully, and
you can start making requests,
which we indicate here via
simple Boolean.
There's a number of
ways to do that.
If there's an error, you can log
it, and there's a number
of different other things that
you can do, which you can hear
about tomorrow.
Second field is Client ID.
Your application or site needs
to be able to identify itself
to Google uniquely so that
we know what app or site
corresponds to the activities.
And that's done through the
use of a Client ID.
You can set up your Client ID
at cloud.google.com/console,
and then click Register App.
You'll go through a flow, of
which I've shown a couple of
details here, that allows you
to select the type of app or
site that you're talking about,
and then add certain
metadata associated with it.
In the case of a web
application, all you need to
do is indicate that it is a web
application, and then copy
and paste in all the host
origins on which
your script may exist.
Between the two of these,
Google's APIs will be able to
validate that the client ID is
legitimate, and then therefore
know who your app is
and who you are.
Finally, I'll talk about this
requestvisibleactions field
just to call out again that all
these activities that you
post on behalf of your users are
done with their consent.
When you pass
requestvisibleactions equals
this value to Google, what it
does is triggers the consent
dialogue to ask the user, is
it all right for us to send
activities on your behalf?
Supposing they consent, your
JavaScript callback will get
an access token.
And from there you can start
sending activities.
So finally, let's talk about
what it looks like to actually
send those activities.
And this is also very simple,
so simple that the amount of
JavaScript necessary can
fit on one slide with
fairly large text.
There are two pieces associated
with this.
One, there's a simple "if"
conditional that says, was the
sign-in flow successful
to begin with?
And there's a number of
different pieces of logic you
can put in there, depending
on your integration.
But most importantly,
you create a moment.
The Google Moments API allows
you to send different types of
what we call moments-- in this
particular case, an activity--
to Google.
There are only two pieces of
data associated with an
activity that are absolutely
required-- one, the type.
There are a number of
different types.
In this particular example,
I'm saying the user has
listened to something,
and that something is
identified by a URL.
And that's all it is.
From there, you use the Google
Client, which already has the
access token which has been
granted by the user going
through the consent
flow to it.
And you simply just post this to
the moments vault, which is
the URL for the moments API.
From there, Google knows that
the activity has occurred, and
you're pretty much done.
The result of this can
be used as well, for
logging and other purposes.
But for the purposes of Popular
on Google+, that is
all you need to do.
So at this point, if we go back
to the Popular on Google+
section, let's think about it.
What do we know how to do?
We know who's doing what on
your site, and to what.
So we can display the account,
basically by
uniquifying the URLs.
And we know that that
number of users has
performed that activity.
The last piece of data that we
need is data about what that
URL actually corresponds to.
And the way that we do that is
by requesting that sites add
schema.org markup
to their page.
Now, schema.org is an open
standard that simply just
involves adding additional
attributes to existing HTML to
tell us more about what it is,
semantically speaking.
Now, Google is really good at
inferring meaning from HTML.
But at the same time, schema.org
allows you to
specifically indicate what
that content is.
Is it a song?
What is its duration?
What language are we
talking about?
It basically takes the guesswork
out, and really
makes it much more
deterministic.
And it's an incredibly
powerful technique.
But I will start by talking
about a simple example here,
corresponding to a song.
Now, take a look
at this markup.
It's very simple.
Obviously, it would be more
complex, in all likelihood, on
a real site, but it really
gets the point across.
This represents a displayed
representation of a song.
You can see there's an image.
There's the BBC Radio 93.5 is
the name associated with it.
There's genre information.
But is all this kind of in
a mishmash of divs and
spans and all this.
There's a listen control
at the bottom.
It's actually kind of ironic
that most, or at least many
websites, are generated from
structured content, and
completely lose it
on the way out.
Schema.org allows you to put
those semantics back in.
So how do you do this?
The first thing you do is by
circumscribing the universe of
discourse that you're talking
about, simply just by adding
the itemscope property to
the top-level div that
encapsulates all the information
about this song.
Itemscope basically just
says, this is a thing.
The next attribute you add
is itemtype, which says
what type it is.
The types are all enumerated at
schema.org/docs/full.html.
In this particular case,
we're talking
about a music recording.
Now within the type of music
recording, a lot of additional
attributes can apply, that
map very directly to this
particular DOM.
All of these are marked via
itemprop attributes.
So you just add itemprop
to the DOM accordingly.
You'll notice that we've marked
where there's an image,
what the name of the music
recording is in this
particular case, the
genre, and the
language which it occurs.
There may be a bunch of
additional data on the page.
Now, that's fairly
straightforward.
When Google's crawlers get to
this content, it allows us to
pull all these fields out,
sanitize them appropriately,
and render them directly and
meaningfully in the Popular on
Google+ box.
It's an incredibly powerful
technique, and something that
extends well beyond the Popular
on Google+ box.
So I suggest that you take a
look at schema.org if you have
any interest in it, because this
is the sort of thing that
will continue to pay dividends
over time.
Today, Popular on Google+
supports two different types
of schema.org markup,
corresponding to a number of
different types of activity
to which that could occur.
This is in the music and
movies verticals.
So for music, the schema.org
type is music
recording, as you see.
You can listen, discover, or buy
that, or at least indicate
that your users are doing so.
And for movies, discover, buy,
want, and review are the
applicable activities.
But of course, the team is
working extremely hard to
expand the types of entities
that are understood, as well
as being able to represent of
those entities in a much more
fluid way, in a much more
meaningful way.
Popular on Google+ is really
only the beginning of this
integration.
ARDAN ARAC: Thanks, John.
I'll say the closing words.
So basically, we showed you
today how you can really jazz
up your brand queries.
But as the search team and the
social team and with this
partnership, our goal is to go
way, way beyond brand queries.
And the better we understand
your app, your site,
individuals' relationship to
you, either through the Follow
action or the user activities
that you're writing to us, the
better we understand the
content and how it is
consumed, the better we
can represent you.
This gives us a new
understanding of how what
users are doing, how they're
consuming, which
user cares about you.
All this stuff is just a wealth
of information that
will keep enriching the
search experience.
And we started with brand
queries, and I hope this talk
and the examples and showed you
were exciting enough for
you to go and put that half an
hour of work in to activate
your Google+ page, or one week
of one engineer's work to
integrate Google Sign-In, but
there's a lot more to come.
So thank you.
JOHN HJELMSTAD: Thank
you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
JOHN HJELMSTAD: So we've
got plenty of time.
If you would like, we are open
to the mic for questions.
AUDIENCE: I'm just curious
how current search engine
placement and whatnot for
our old search engine
optimization, how that
comes into play here.
Does it improve?
Does it even come into
play at all?
JOHN HJELMSTAD: Ardan?
ARDAN ARAC: So basically, we
have, at least with all the
features we showed you today,
we haven't really changed
anything in the central column
in terms of ranking.
It's all on the right
hand side.
AUDIENCE: So regarding the
ranking on the search results,
the first result is what's going
to determine the card on
the right, correct?
JOHN HJELMSTAD: That's right.
AUDIENCE: Is it possible for a
single Google+ page, so let's
say TMZ for example, to trigger
on TMZ, a search for
that, and also for
celebrity news?
Does it matter, as long as
they're the number one ranking
for that term?
ARDAN ARAC: No, not
at the moment.
So basically, because there are,
of course, other sites--
like Paris Hilton also is
in celebrity news--
at least at this point, we
don't choose which +Page
applies to a more
generic query.
So the feature currently
is pretty tightly
tied to brand queries.
AUDIENCE: So have to
specifically have a search for
your brand name for
that to appear.
ARDAN ARAC: Yes.
AUDIENCE: OK.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Can you hear me?
JOHN HJELMSTAD: Yep.
AUDIENCE: You talked about
+Page, but there's a lot of
talk on the web, like, for local
pages, business pages.
Are we talking about
the same thing?
Because lately, you've being
mentioning all these different
definitions of pages.
So is it +Page, local pages, or
are there different things?
JOHN HJELMSTAD: For the purposes
of this integration,
we're just talking
about +Pages.
There may be additional features
that we add similar
to this that are inspired by its
hope for success, but for
right now, we're just talking
about +Pages.
AUDIENCE: Like for the
Google local pages
from Maps or something?
Or local businesses,
I mean, there--
ARDAN ARAC: Those are
also hosted on
Google+, as far as I know.
JOHN HJELMSTAD: Yeah, so that's
just a different type
of page associated with this.
But for now, we're really just
talking about brand queries,
so corresponds to product
or brand searches.
ARDAN ARAC: But there is an
internationalization component.
That brings me to
a good point.
So for example, in the case of
Starbucks, there can be a
global Starbucks page,
like in English.
So that is the content that
would show in most cases, at
least for queries in English.
But then maybe Starbucks Japan
chose to also have an identity
and a page where they post
Japanese content.
So we definitely look
at the localization.
So for query Starbucks in Japan,
the content would come
from their Japan page.
And for the query in English,
it would come from their
English page, or the page
associated with the US.
And things can get even more
localized for local
businesses, to like state,
city levels.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: You have support for
authorship tying into Google+,
so if somebody authors
a page, they show up.
But you don't do that
for brands.
You don't have any kind of a
form of publishership, so that
even though we have the ability
to tie our logos--
we can tie our pages back to
Google+, but you don't show,
say, our organizational
information in little profiles
next to it the way you
do with authors.
So can you talk about if
that's going to come?
And also, just today, you've--
I mean, an hour ago, you
announced that you're
supporting company logos.
But you're not using
Google+ for that.
You're using schema instead.
ARDAN ARAC: No, the logos I
showed at the top, like the
TuneIn logo, that comes
from Google+.
That doesn't come--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
understand that.
I'm talking about, like, you
understand authorship.
Somebody's written an article.
They'd link to authorship,
right?
ARDAN ARAC: So we didn't really
touch upon authorship,
but that is something I think
about a lot, and a lot of
people on my team also does.
So basically, who is the
face behind content.
And we talk about the
voice of TuneIn,
the voice of Starbucks.
But sometimes within that
umbrella is the voice of a
particular author, like
someone's name is
associated with that.
So we didn't go into that, but
there are ways of actually
linking pages to individuals,
+Pages, and that's who gets
[INAUDIBLE].
JOHN HJELMSTAD: I think that's
what he's mentioning.
He's wondering what would happen
if a brand essentially
was the publisher, or at
least wanted that to--
AUDIENCE: Well, are there plans
to allow brands to have
that kind of linkage, as opposed
to just their authors?
So if "The New York Times"
wanted to show up, and you
list "The New York Times,"
the "New York Times"--
JOHN HJELMSTAD: If you said,
by "New York Times,"
essentially.
AUDIENCE: --might like
to have their logo.
ARDAN ARAC: Yeah, I mean I don't
know the details of that
feature all that much.
But I guess--
JOHN HJELMSTAD: Yeah, I mean
it's something that we've
considered.
And I think the team is trying
to figure out all the
nuances with it.
Because I think part--
and don't quote me too heavily
on this-- part of it is really
trying to provide the personal
touch, essentially, of who
specifically wrote it, as
opposed to providing a
different sort of clearinghouse
for kind of like
an umbrella of authorship.
[INAUDIBLE].
But there's a number of really
legitimate use cases for it
too, and so I could try to meet
you afterwards, and get
you in touch with the
PMs for that.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I was wondering if you had a
roadmap for the other schema
that are already entities.
So currently it's just
movies and music.
Do you give a published roadmap
of the support for the
other ones, specifically for
the local business entity?
ARDAN ARAC: Yeah.
Actually, that's definitely
something we're interested in.
I don't have a roadmap slide to
show, but it really depends
on two things.
One is like, what idea, what
use case really strikes us?
And I'd actually love
to your ideas.
You know your service.
You know your content.
We have office hours
right after this.
So if you come to that and say,
hey, here's how we think
you could use our data in
Google, like, that's how-- the
best ideas come from you,
so that's part one.
But part two, what really
convinces us to focus on a
certain vertical or a certain
use case is also the data that
we're seeing coming through.
Like, if I see a lot of data
coming from apps, sites that
are about local businesses,
then we're like, OK, let's
look deeper into this, what we
can do with this, as opposed
to just talking the
hypothetical.
So another way of sort of
getting your use case to the
front of the queue is actually
sending us data integrating
the Google+ Sign-In.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ARDAN ARAC: Sorry, what?
AUDIENCE: Where can
we get the slides?
JOHN HJELMSTAD: I think that'll
end up being posted on
the I/O site after the talk.
AUDIENCE: My name and personal
brand happen to clash with an
Italian design heiress
and an Austrian DJ.
Neither one of those has yet
woken up to this and how to
use it and to use it.
Now, I've the brand, domain,
got all that in place.
I've claimed my +Page.
So at this point in time, it
should be very easy for me to
get it all set up.
Now meanwhile, sooner or
later, one or both--
probably both of those two--
are going to wake
up to what's happening.
I'm just a little guy.
They, on the other hand,
are actually
quite famous, big entities.
What happens then, if
it's the same brand?
ARDAN ARAC: Right.
So this is a hard problem, so
I'm just going to venture my
sort of thought-- like, this is
not a product definition.
But, how I would fix that
is, the key is really
understanding the user's
relationship to
you or to that brand.
So if I know-- like, the basic
example-- if the user follows
you when they search for you,
the likelihood that they're
looking for you is high.
Or another user has signed into
their page with their
Google+ whatever identity, also
the likelihood that they
are interested in
that is high.
So these are very explicit
signals, and they're not as
common as we would like.
But that's kind of the answer,
understanding--
and maybe if my friend
is following you,
that's another signal.
So I guess one way to solve
that is really understand
which user is interested
in which brand.
JOHN HJELMSTAD: And just
expanding upon that a little
bit, of a lot of times we've
seen brand names that are
claimed in, like, Italy versus
the United States-- very
simple, right?
That's yet another axis along
which search can be a little
bit more intelligent, based on
geolocation, based on what
language you're searching
in, things of that sort.
And then also, things that we
are rolling out having to do
with automatic hashtagging and
semantic analysis associated
with your content.
If we know that somebody's
very interested in shoes,
maybe we'll show Jimmy Choo.
But if somebody's interested
in Jimmy Choo the website
maker or something, then
we would trigger that.
But it's very early days
when it comes to the
search aspect of that.
AUDIENCE: It's going to be
very much contextual and
relational then?
ARDAN ARAC: Yeah.
JOHN HJELMSTAD: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you very much.
AUDIENCE: Quick question on--
you guys talked about on the
right hand column,
pretty much.
So I just wanted to know how
would that get incorporated
with mobile searches or tablet
searches, et cetera.
Is that going to be included
in mobile as well, or--
ARDAN ARAC: The question's
about mobile?
JOHN HJELMSTAD: Mobile
and other displays.
ARDAN ARAC: Good
question, yeah.
So we started with desktop.
Like right now, this
is available--
everything we showed is
available on desktop, but
we're working on
mobile as well.
JOHN HJELMSTAD: Pretty much
anywhere else that search
results would show up, we seek
to integrate it in the most
contextual and non-intrusive
way.
AUDIENCE: And the desktop one's
already public already?
JOHN HJELMSTAD: Yes, for
movies and music.
Of course, we'll be rolling
out to more
categories over time.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
JOHN HJELMSTAD: It doesn't
appear that there's any
questions from the
extended sites.
So if there's any more here?
One more.
AUDIENCE: How would this
integrate with the cards?
Would it?
ARDAN ARAC: What cards?
AUDIENCE: Well, like Google
Glass cards or Google Now
cards, will you ever see
with a Google Now like
this being the top--
ARDAN ARAC: Oh, I see.
Like Google Now cards?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ARDAN ARAC: That
is a good idea.
We haven't really thought
about that.
JOHN HJELMSTAD: I mean, it's
another one of the visual form
factors that we're looking into,
to see what the user
experience will be like, whether
it be too cluttered,
whether or not it will provide
contextual and relevant
information.
Anecdotally and intuitively
speaking, it
seems like it would.
And I think that the
teams will continue
to integrate more.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
JOHN HJELMSTAD: That's all
the time we've got.
ARDAN ARAC: Thank you.
JOHN HJELMSTAD: Thanks
for your time.